i'm julia child
bon appetit julia child was the first
chef who became
famous on television but she wasn't a
restaurant chef she never had a
restaurant what she did
is she made people understand that
cooking should be fun that you can be
all together as a family and i think she
inspired a lot of american especially
women to become chefs hello this is
wolfgang puck and this is part two of
the breakdown
[Music]
first up bird
i thought the moves were maybe right you
know how things go back and forth but i
don't want to look at the shoes of some
waiter or chef or whatever i thought
that was weird i'm not sure i would look
at the person
how they move with their hand because
it's really about their hands
what's with the bus chef chef the menu
it looked to me like they were tasting
the food and tasting the wine
to go with it like almost a food and
wine bearing and see
maybe how the two different things gonna
make it into one
great experience in a restaurant where
you have a sommelier
somebody responsible for the wine and
knows generally much more about wine
than the chef
the chef might know more about the taste
so if they work together
maybe they can make the perfect
experience if you have the right
combination the right wine
with the right dish often i see people
in restaurants
they start they have oysters they have
some seafood appetizer whatever it
is but they already ordered their
cabernet sauvignon
things like that a good red wine and
then they have oysters on the table or
crab on the table which would be great
with a good
crisp white wine a glass of champagne so
to me it's really important to have the
right wine
with the food
on you
when we organize a menu when we do new
things
it's never a whole new menu it's always
like an evolution what is available at
the market
so to me that's the way it is and with
wines
it's the same in a way like i tend to
drink jose wines in the summertime when
it's warm outside and
i have them even for an aperitif
sometimes but
in the wintertime i might drink a
heavier red wine
so to me the season flows not only with
food but also with wine
aprons
[Music]
the chef is putting down the heating
lights these are lights but actually
they are heating the plates so
that way if a plate gets put on the pass
where the
waiters pick up the food you put their
lights down the heaters down so that way
the food stays hot
[Music]
very often you see now in restaurants
chefs
using flowers for example for color
some of them for taste too but more for
color so if you put the flour of a
garlic chives it will have
flavor if you put in a stir some flour
it will have this peppery flavor
so not only it will make the dish look
beautiful but also tastes good i want to
have
both i want it to look good but first of
all it has to be delicious
not just to throw something on it and
say okay now it looks better it has to
have purpose
if i read a review good or bad obviously
everybody out there gonna say if the
review
is great we'll say the food critic is
really good
if they write a bad review we said food
critic sucks
so somewhere in the middle is the right
thing i
really believe that we are maybe not as
great as somebody said
or not as bad as somebody would say
somewhere in the middle east maybe the
right balance because
a lot of these food critics from
newspapers
go with a preconceived notion to a
restaurant so they know
already ah this is a fancy restaurant
let's hit them over the head a little
bit or this is a hole in the wall
let's make them look really good i went
to some restaurants when i read the
review i said wow this is amazing and
then i went i said
what was the guy smoking to write like
that about this restaurant you know so
i think the food critic for better for
most
have very little power today in
comparison the way it was
30 40 years ago a foot critic of the new
york times the elliot times or san
francisco paper wherever
when they wrote a great review about
your restaurant
you know you would be full for six
months these days
social media is the real critic of the
restaurant
next up julie and julia tuesday august
13
2002 day one 364 days to go
julia child was a great friend of mine
we cooked many times
together julia child was the first chef
who became
famous on television but she wasn't a
restaurant chef she never had the
restaurant
what she did is she put american people
in the kitchen that it's okay you can
cook if you screw it up just throw it
away what what can you do with it
but she made people understand the
cooking should be fun that you can be
all
together as a family and i think she
inspired a lot of american especially
women to become chefs
i cooked artichokes with hollandaise
sauce which is melted butter that's been
whipped
into a frenzy with egg yolks until it's
died and gone to heaven
and let me say this is there anything
better than butter
you know butter is really amazing and
they say butter taste
everything better which is right in a
way because
if you have a simple grilled fish and
put butter on it tastes better if you
have a steak and you put butter on it it
tastes better in whatever version you
put it
every time you taste something that's
delicious beyond imagining
and you say what is in this the answer
is always going to be
butter if you make a sauce a reduction
and then you finish it with butter it
ties the whole thing together
makes it smooth makes it really more
velvety tasting
it just makes it taste better if you
have
like in a movie artichokes and you make
a hollandaise it's basically egg yolk
which is fat and then you add a lot of
butter to it and season it with a little
lemon juice like cayenne and salt and
pepper
and it will taste delicious with
anything
i think chef might rely in french
restaurants too much on butter they put
butter on their bread they put butter in
the sauces they put butter in the
soup i don't think it's necessary if you
have the ingredients
taste really delicious and they're
really fresh
and they're grown in the right places i
like the purity of the dishes sometimes
without butter
next up waiting three more minutes to
the wall drought baby come on
oh hi there you're not closed yet are
you
i'm not quite oh terrific i believe this
scene is totally overplayed i never saw
it happen in a restaurant or in
restaurants i frequent or in one of our
restaurants i don't know if they were so
happy
or so upset uh i think it's not a
reality
sorry guys
it's so interesting because i have
people come to the restaurant really
late
even in the old time when i was the only
one there
one time jack nicholson came from
somewhere really late
we closed the kitchen and he said wolfer
what's to eat
and i said oh what would you like meat
or fish or
it said okay cook me some fish give me
some pecan pie
and i made it for him and i stayed
instead of going home
at 11 i stayed until 12 o'clock
especially if we know them if they're
regulars we will cook for them
but if somebody comes not appropriately
dressed you see they
don't fit really into the restaurant we
said i'm sorry we are closed
next up overboard i prepared and handled
raw food
i hunt it you cook it you shot a chicken
come on honey save the jokes we're
starving here yeah
probably gonna make chicken soup i think
the pot is way too small
to make chicken soup i think you can
cook it whole if you want to for sure
but hopefully they took out the
intestines
we had many fires in the kitchen as a
matter of fact we had one in washington
in our restaurant where they didn't
do their ventilation right so the whole
thing caught fire
we had to evacuate the restaurant so it
was very problematic and sometimes that
you know we all have hoods in the
restaurant if the hoods are not cleaned
properly
they can catch fire and then the fire
extinguisher go off
and we have to close the restaurant i
remember one time
we had a fire at sinoa with oil which is
very dangerous
and some stupid guy put water in the hot
oil and
then it flamed up like crazy so the fire
trucks came and everything so i think we
had a few fires
i'll get the burn i mean you'll be all
right
[Applause]
injuries in the kitchen have changed so
much i remember
the first time i got injured and really
badly burned
my whole arm was in dijon my first
restaurant in france
i did not speak french it was the first
week i was there
i stayed at the hospital overnight and i
still remember i was on the operating
table they took off pieces of skin and i
was lying i said god i don't know what
they're gonna do with me
and then i stayed overnight and then
they let me go i went back to the
restaurant
and i started to work the next day with
heavy banded around but it was so hot i
also had splatters in the face
so just being in the kitchen was so
painful
you know if you don't focus a hundred
percent it's very easy
to cut into your fingers burn yourself
well hustle guys you alright
you know practice makes better so i
think the next time she's gonna make a
chicken soup she's probably gonna get a
big pot so the chicken fits in there
and figure it out or cut it in half or
into pieces
in cooking just like anything else
practice makes
better you want to be sure to be able to
execute
all right thanks for watching the clip
with me see you next time